- [Voiceover] It's 5:35 in the morning.
- You should never wake up in darkness
if the sun isn't out, that's a sign
that whatever you're
doing, it's not worth it.
- I just got in my car, I'm pretty tired.
- And I am on my way to a dance party.
- Why?
(techno music)
- I've been to a couple of these before
and I thought they were really fun
so I told Jen and Maycie
and Ryan from the Testies,
or the Test Friends, but
I call 'em the Testies
'cause it's a great name,
and Zach from the Try Guys.
I invited them to come to this party
to see what they think of it.
- I think I can do this.
Gonna go, we're gonna try and dance.
- It's actually crazy,
there are so many cars
and so many people, and
I don't understand why.
- It is 6:35 in the
morning, we're gonna dance
and then we're gonna go to work,
and it's gonna be fucking awesome.
- Tired.
- I feel okay, I don't really
like dance parties at night.
- No, yeah.
- Well
- Yeah, ehh
- I don't know, it just feels weird,
like why do people do this?
- I feel like the only
people who wake up early
to go dancing are like
beautiful, fit people.
And Henry.
- This is probably the
weirdest / silliest thing
I've ever done on a work
day, it's a Tuesday.
(techno music)
- Daybreaker started about a
year and a half ago in New York
and then it's almost our
one year anniversary in LA.
It's a way to get people
out of their normal routine
to have fun in the morning,
and then go to work
and change the world.
- This gathering is just about,
the energy that we create together
to supercharge our day, our week, our life
it's not serious, it's
just fun for everyone.
(techno music)
(Maycie laughs)
- It's incredible
- It's pretty amazing
- Oh yeah, facepaint and bodypaint on us,
which is pretty rad.
- I feel like it looks
kinda cool, so I'm into it.
- I haven't had coffee
today, but I feel great
- [Voicover] You know
there's coffee in there
- I don't care
- Yeah, we had weird watermelon
rind drink, pretty good
- Yeah, I had watermelon
juice instead of coffee
because I wanted to challenge
myself, like do I need coffee?
No, I wanna be energized
by dance, and guess what?
I am.
- I just want to say that right now
I'd normally be just getting
up and feeling super groggy,
and I feel incredible right now instead.
- Yeah, I wouldn't even be
getting up for 20 more minutes.
- You would think, it's light
out so people are judging,
but because it's light
out I think it's just
come as you are, who
cares, have a good time.
People are really accepting in there!
We joined a dance line, and
there were these awesome dancers
teaching us dance moves, I
learned this thing, pretty cool
- Yeah I didn't really keep up with it.
- Nah I got it, I got this, I'm good.
- I definitely wouldn't
describe this as a rave
it's almost like a work
out class in the morning
but with dancing.
- It seems to be a more
genuine, positive time
I did not see a single
person grind up on a girl
and like try and do that,
except for right now
now it's happening.
- Not for lack of trying.
We tried to make it happen
earlier, it didn't work.
- Blanketly describing it,
'cause I'm gonna be like
there's this really crazy,
sober, 6 am dance party
it sounds really weird,
it is really weird,
but you should try it,
'cause it's also really fun.
- I feel great, I feel like I
enjoyed it more than you did.
- You know what, I think what it is
is for me, you have to be able to dance,
you have to like, be not
self conscious at all,
and I'm not sure I'm there
necessarily when I'm sober.
- I saw a new side of Henry Goldman today
I did not know he had those moves,
he busted 'em out, it was pretty rad.
- It takes a special kind of person
to be able to get up very early,
come to a dance party and just let loose.
- Yeah, us.
- Yeah, this type of person!
(people cheering)
- I'm dancing sober as fuck
at 6:30 in the morning.